uh hmm all right mr. knife you done cut
me deep
just to see Ron sorry about that you
just bit of glue might be able to put it
back together again and now just go to
my casa come alright momentum got me oh
look it's a gritty reboot get it up I'm
a ninja
I'm a ninja I'm a ninja yeah oh yeah oh
it wasn't so hard yeah now is the winter
of our discontent sorry I'm just trying
to break it up a bit with her reactions
no ha ha ha ha
that's a bit chilly now isn't it some a
bit dirty I don't think they'll mind
excuse me it was this piece of toast
drop on the floor no sir not at all
actually he's been cleaning the entire
time [ __ ] and span just from the loaf to
the toaster wouldn't it be easy for you
do that so here's me doing a little
Assassin's green and I got it all right
this better be worth it what yeah yeah
please get a house cleaner or something
this is disgusting I think it might have
been easier if I just go to the
telephone and ring someone to carry me
over to the toaster no huh hmm I'm going
to be light bright after all this and at
last there's no stair all right toast me
go on toast me hair it is nice and brown
alpha god state I don't put myself in ok
almost there got it see oh but it's
actually quite from our feeling
mmm ok this one
that's quite a bit warmer than I
expected tip Dan died